when discussing the polish-lithuanian
Commonwealth it's common to use Poland
as a shorthand for it part of this is
out of these but part of it is also
because common imagery from Poland
Lithuania is overwhelmingly associated
with Poland the winged hussars polish
the liberum veto polish getting carved
up by a Russian and German speaking
neighbors polish this raises the
question just how Lithuanian was the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
now there are many metrics you can use
to determine just how lift-away knee in
the commonwealth was and of course this
varied over time that perhaps it's
easiest to simply look at a map of the
territory
so the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
was divided into several constituent
lands the two main ones were the kingdom
of Poland and the Grand Duchy of
Lithuania the Commonwealth also had
separately administered puppet fiefdom
the Duchy of Courland the duchy of
livonia and most notably the duchy of
prussia so in terms of territory as we
can see the kingdom of poland was
dominant if not overwhelmingly so
although you should know that this was
only because lithuania ceded this
territory to them at the creation of the
Commonwealth the population of Poland
Lithuania at the turn of the sixteenth
century was just over seven and a half
million people by the time it reached
its peak in 1618 it was about 11 million
the kingdom of Poland was the larger of
the two halves and was home to about six
million people at its peak of which four
million were polish in the Lithuanian
half of the Commonwealth there were
about three million people of which
about 1 million were lithuanian now as
you all have noticed that means that
Lithuania were a minority within not
only the Commonwealth but within their
own half of it and in terms of ethnic
composition the Commonwealth looked like
this with the Polish bring the largest
group followed by ruthenians ukrainians
lithuanian germans and then jews he
would seem they're not its height the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth was only
about 10% Lithuanian but this doesn't
answer the question fully since surely
the Lithuanian Swaroop resented in the
ruling and wealthy classes right well
sort of let's look at language polish
was an official language of the
Commonwealth along with German Latin
Hebrew and of course Lithuanian oh wait
no Lithuanian wasn't actually an
official language that was Ruthenian in
fact none of the rulers of the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth had spoken
Lithuanian for over 100 years at this
point
so Lithuanian were over-represented in
the nobility in the merchant classes but
since the Union had begun they were
increasingly sidelined in fact much of
the Grand Duchy of Lithuania were
subject to pollenization that is being
made to become polish culturally in
lithuanian largely weren't seen as he
cause this was made worse by the fact
that the Grand Duchy took on the
administrative methods of the Polish
Kingdom and that there were many in
Lithuania that embraced the Polish way
of doing things in importance Vilnius
the capital of the Grand Duchy was seen
as secondary to the Polish capital
Cracow young lithuanian nobles would
learn polish marry into polish families
and disregard their old way of life in
order to better their social standing
that's not to say that all lithuanian
embrace this the grand duchy was still a
separate legal entity in the lithuanian
had their own military units two units
from the Grand Duchy made up about 1/3
of the Commonwealth's military strength
for Lithuanians as well as poles letters
into battle and whilst there were lit
the way nians within the famed wing to
Tsar's they were overwhelmingly polish
as such it can safely be said that
despite being a whole half of the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth the Commonwealth
wasn't all to Lithuanian at its height
Lithuanian made up roughly 1/10 of the
Commonwealth's population and over time
the Lithuanian lands became ever more
silent by its governing authorities all
of this combined with the polish half
holding the superior royal title hosting
the capital being much more urbanized to
being home to the world-famous wing to
Tsar's it's unsurprising that we
associate the Commonwealth with Poland
and in fact this view is an accurate one
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with extra thanks
to my patrons that you see on screen now
and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologist szarka
flash party boy Co Rob Waterhouse Yashar
Enderman Chris wicker Myles Bailey Brent
guard Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan tun
Rick onion duck
Maggie packs Kowski Winston Cawood
vasily our Vedas Anthony Beckett Adam
Harvey Ike Skye Chappell and the
amusement park Ives